it's a monday edition of pftpm
and we have a guest today a guest who
has a lot of game balls back there chris
harris jr you have won a lot of game
balls during your time in the nfl and
i'm sure they've all been richly
deserved chris terrace
chargers cornerback i gotta get used to
saying that i used to say i'm broncos
chargers quarterback i love the hat i
love the game balls welcome back it's
great to see you for the first time as a
charger we saw at the super bowl you
were still a bronco
yeah man it feels good um kind of just
just making sure i'm ready uh we had a
great offseason of being able to
implement the new defense and everything
so i'm excited man i feel like i feel
great uh coming into the season
how hard is it though to do the virtual
off-season program jumping to a new team
your first new team since you came to
the nfl what's the difference between
this year's experience going through the
virtual off season and a normal year
yeah
like you said it's a uncomfortable
situation i mean i haven't got to really
meet my teammates face-to-face coaches
included or anybody in the organization
so
uh i'm just jumping in until
once we jump into training camp and uh
so i mean that is different being from
playing in denver for nine years i'm
excited about it i think you get the
most growth when you put you you get put
in uncomfortable situations so i'm
looking at looking at it that way and
taking it as a challenge and um uh and
uh just uh just to make sure i have a
great year this year
do you ever
sit back and look at what you've
accomplished undrafted how hard that is
to just make the roster much less become
a star player how much time do you spend
just thinking wow i really have come a
long way in nine years in the nfl
oh yeah definitely and um just just
really it's all hard work perseverance
and uh i'm just just
god just taking me to levels that i
never thought i could go and you know
and it's really what it's what it is and
right now i can relate to guys because i
was here during the lockout where um we
was a similar situation as it is now
and i had to go and jump and make the
team
fast without having the offseason with
the team so guys can relate to me i can
kind of share my story with them and and
try to give them a little tips of what i
think they need to do to make sure
they're ready to go once training camp
comes that's a great point i mean it's
hard enough to make it as an undrafted
free agent in a year where you have the
off season program you did it where
training camps started in early august
once they resolved the lockout looking
back what was the one thing that allowed
you to get the attention of the coaching
staff and the front office and survive
those cuts and make it to the final
roster
well mike everybody's smart i mean
everybody can play you know everybody
has a lot of talent but i think uh what
really separated me was being uh smart
being able to learn multiple positions
be able to play corner safety or nickel
and being pretty good at all of them and
i think that's what really separated
myself and able to make the team and
able to find myself on the field early
um as a rookie yeah and to really uh
really exceed
um and i i really i really believe
that's why
you know when we met at the super bowl
there had been plenty of talk about your
future the broncos hadn't resigned you
and i know you would have liked to have
stayed there if they made the right
offer if they made the fair offer at the
end of the day though how hard was it to
say goodbye to the only place you'd ever
been in the nfl
i was definitely hard it wasn't easy um
you know
that's that's that's your first love you
know it's always hard to lose your first
love and uh it was just a situation
where um it was just time to to to go
our separate ways and um and you see
that happen a lot in the nfl you see
that happening a lot in sports not a lot
of players are able to play on one team
their whole career you even seen it with
peyton manning so it was just my time to
transition and go somewhere else and
move on and
and i'm at peace with it now i feel
great um going in in my decision to
to go with the charges
you play with a lot of head coaches in
denver from
gary kubiak before that john fox right
uh and then there was vance joseph
ultimately vic fangio
tell me about your new head coach
anthony lynn what about him has stood
out to you in your limited time of
having not working directly with him but
having that opportunity to hear from him
and see him through the virtual meetings
man coach lynn he's a guy
what really i liked is that he's so
hungry to win now
um the urgency that he he comes with and
he he approaches us with is just having
a high urgency to win now and um that's
what i wanted i want guys in the
organization that are that's they're
trying to get over that hump they're
trying to win now so that's a really
spark sparked my attention with coach
lynn
what do you know about training camp
what it's going to be like is it going
to open on time and any other issues
relating to the impact of the pandemic
on football
yeah i don't know anything i know that
um i think they're they're supposed to
be some type of vote or something with
the nflpa the doctors whatever
um and uh trying to figure that out come
i think by mid-july or so what's going
to be the schedule and how we're going
to do it
but it's you never know what's going to
happen man it could be
you've been seeing a lot of outbreaks
happen a lot of people lately of
have tested positive for it lately so
you never know what's gonna happen with
me i'm just taking it day by day man
that's all you can do is uh just take it
day by day and if hopefully uh they
allow us to play football you know um
that's something that i think uh
football unites everybody and that's
what we need
you know and i look at it from the
perspective of how i would have felt if
i was 21 22 23 going through this
probably a different mindset than if i
was entering year 10 from your
perspective how do you balance concerns
about the virus concerns about family
members potentially getting it with the
desire to play football and with the
belief that even though you've been
around 10 years you're too young to have
a serious outcome if you would catch it
yeah well with me is i know i can beat
it i know that uh i can
try to fight through it the best that i
can
but it was just worried about my four
little girls and my wife and my family
uh i don't um that's that's where that's
where definitely i have a big issue with
that it's just not putting them in
danger not me putting them in danger i
don't want to be the cause of them
getting sick or anything from them so um
that's where the worry some comes from
but
uh with me i know i can beat it i know i
can fight and try to fight through it
i've seen vine he fight through it so
you've seen a lot of people fight
through it and be able to overcome but
it's just uh me it's just uh putting
other people in harm's way
have you heard anything from vaughn
about what he went through it seems like
from time to time he had some real
concerns it wasn't just everything's
fine
you know i got the cold i got the flu
whatever the case may be i got the
impression he had some real concerns
that he could have had some serious
health effects
well uh if anybody knows bond he had he
has asthma issues so then um
so
when i seen him get it definitely
definitely um
a spark issue with me because you know
because he already knew he had asthma
problems so
but i he was able to overcome it he said
it was real
the symptoms are serious and that people
should definitely take it seriously so
just um listening to him and
and his approach on it and how he had to
fight through it um definitely made me
know that it is real because that's one
of my best friends and i see them you
see him being affected by it um it
definitely becomes real to you what's it
been like trying to stay in shape
without having a team facility to go to
and having to find other ways to be in
the kind of condition and strength that
you need to be yeah uh for me my
training hasn't changed uh we've been
able to keep our gym open uh but just
limit how many people i work out with
and um stay on my same routine i've been
in the past i've been with my trainer uh
for nine years so being able to stay on
my same routine
i haven't missed a beat so i'm ready to
go i feel great and i'm just just
whenever there whenever it's time to go
and whenever it's time to play i know
i'm be ready to go
the past three months have been unlike
any that i can recall from the
coronavirus to the george floyd murder
in the aftermath of that the awakening
by so many in america when it comes to
issues of racial equality and social
justice you recently wrote a letter that
appeared on the players tribune a letter
to your four daughters tell me a little
bit about what prompted the letter and
the message that you'd like to get
across
to children everywhere of all races who
may be looking at these times and
wondering what in the world is going on
well really um really i just uh led in
my spirit just to really
reach out to all black young uh women
really really all really all black women
to really see that letter uh but mainly
younger women uh that's the main focus i
was really focusing on and just to show
them that they can overcome they're
smart they um they're they're strong and
i just want to encourage them and to
build them up and uh because you don't
see that a lot i don't see that a lot
and um i wanted to be just a guy to
stick my neck out for them and to
encourage them
and to continue to do what they're doing
it seemed like before george floyd if a
guy would stick his neck out there would
be maybe some hesitation concern for
repercussions concern for criticism that
really has all gone away i've seen a lot
of people standing up saying what they
believe and whatever the repercussions
are they are how has it felt for you
personally has it felt like there's a
weight off of you that allows you to say
what you believe when you believe it
uh no i don't think that none of that
really bothered me i think this is just
the timing of the letter i don't think
uh me uh feeling pressured to be able to
speak my mind or anything had to do with
the letter uh or about i do agree with
you it has gave people more chance to be
to speak their mind or be uh to to be
more open about these type of things and
uh
for me i just i just try to not be
distracted
uh just always try to preach love on
people
um unity uh because
uh you can get caught up in uh you can
get caught up and distracted on what's
going on on tv what's going on in the
news
and um and really that take over what's
going on and really take over your mind
so i just try to have a clear mind clear
focus
and just always preach love
and that's what i try to do
you mentioned coach lin's leadership
chris and he's been outspoken about some
of the things he believes some of the
interviews he's done what kinds of
messages has he given directly to the
team about getting through this
difficult time and and getting closer as
a team getting closer as a community and
understanding the the issues that exist
as we try to to make those issues not
issues anymore yeah
oh yeah we had a long hour talk with
coach lynn and he addressed uh
i think he he addressed each group each
position group and
he addresses that as a team
and uh that's what you have to do as a
coach man you have to put everything out
there i think
and
know that you're in tune with the world
know that telling your players you're
into what's going on with the world and
that you feel that you have compassion
with that and when you do that with your
players uh your player is going to write
a dot for you and and that's what he's
done he's been able to show compassion
uh with the situation and and with us
and uh when you do that man um that's
huge that's huge for players
went back to the decision to join the
chargers and this may have come up when
we got together at the super bowl but
you had your chance to get away from
patrick mahomes what are you thinking
staying in the division with patrick
mahomes chris
hey man
you gotta love competition man i've
never been a guy that ran from
competition and uh they're the best
right now they were super bowl champs uh
i know what it feels like to be the
champ after that next year is hard it's
hard to it's hard to duplicate that same
results and uh so uh i mean
everybody's the championship is up for
grabs it's a whole new year and you
gotta prove yourself again
the uh
the chargers have i think one of the
best defenses in the nfl
what stands out to you when you think
about those new teammates knowing that
you came from a team that not long ago
had one of the best defenses of all time
yeah
uh being able to play with all those
guys i mean
one thing i really noticed is that these
guys are already established i mean they
already got pro bowls all pros and me
just joining those guys is just going to
me i'm trying to boost their play try to
um try to raise their game into another
level and
and uh with my knowledge that i have
within the division and just being a
successful player on the field and when
i see darwin james i mean i haven't
played with anybody as talented as
darwin james other than i would say keep
to leave or uh i played with the ladder
and the champ bailey but nobody like
darren james how you can mess up the
game in the secondary so i'm excited
about playing with him uh bosa and
ingram those guys are they they kind of
give me familiarity with vine and d ware
or vine and doomerville how they used to
mess up the game so those guys are
capable of doing the same thing so i'm
excited to join those i think a lot of
fans understand how a defensive lineman
can mess up a game and create havoc up
front when you say a guy like derwen
james can mess up a game from the
secondary give us an example of
something tangible something that he can
do
different than what others would do that
would as you say mess up the game yeah
i mean he can shut out your your best
tight end he can blitz he's a great
blitzer he's um he's great back deep he
can play middle of the field and if
you're trying deep he's able to pick
those off so being able to be versatile
uh being able to play all over the field
and when you got me and you got murray
um i think we got the best nickel
package i don't see a package that's
gonna be as athletic as ours um being
able to cover and have the speed so i'm
excited about uh
what we're going to be able to do
together
and the quarterback's not going to have
a whole lot of time to find a guy open
with guys like joey bosa and melvin
ingram bearing down on them
oh yeah we got the rush too man so i
mean it all works hand in hand and when
we won the super bowl we had great
coverage and we had great pass rush and
um that's what you got to have to be
able to win and
i know that personally from just having
our success and uh in 2015 and really uh
just picking back off each other by
making a play bam then keep to lead
might make a play just we all we all
picky piggy off each other
after 2015 the broncos went through a
revolving door of quarterbacks and last
year it finally landed on drew locke
you're going to be seeing him twice per
year
i think he played incredibly well when
he finally was healthy enough to play
give us a scouting report on what you
saw from a season with drew lock a guy
who looks like he's got a ton of promise
for a guy who felt around two
uh drew one thing with drew he has a lot
of confidence he's a guy that thinks he
can make every throw
now he's learning the system he's uh he
has to learn a whole new system now uh
so it's kind of starting out in square
one but he's a guy he can pick it up
fast
i think and um
uh what we didn't have in the past we
didn't have a guy like that we didn't
have a guy that could have uh confidence
in and uh that displayed to all his
teammates so but i mean it's the proof's
still out there he's still got to go out
there and prove what he can that he can
uh play an elite level consistent uh for
16 games and he had a great five-game
stretch but it's all about the full
season man and that's where um you got
to prove it you get into the charges at
the right time now there may not be any
fans in the stadium but that looks like
it is going to be one of the nicest if
not the nicest sports arena in america
have you gotten a chance to to see
inside pictures of it that maybe aren't
available publicly or any type of access
or information about what it's going to
be like to show up in that new stadium
and play there
not not yet hopefully um when i get
there definitely but
um i think it's going to be a great
attraction i think it will be packed
because um it's just it's going to give
a lot of people something to do out
there but with everything that's going
to happen in it i mean ours is going to
have like a club and it's going to have
a lot of things in it so
it's going to be a great attraction for
people not just only if you want to
just go watch a football game but
entertainment so um i definitely see it
packing now the ultimate attraction
there will be a successful football team
and the competition is going between
the chargers and the rams the and and
having a guy like chris harris around is
going to make a difference for the la
chargers you know this is a team
i don't know why they it feels like
they're overlooked and you've seen them
twice a year every year
why do you think that that there just
tends to be this attitude around the nfl
around fans in the media chargers maybe
aren't one of the better teams when
maybe they are
they definitely are i mean every year
they always have a lot of great talent
and uh really with us um we just knew
that uh we we we never really feared we
feared phillip we knew he was a great
player
but um we we always feel like we could
beat him you know we never really
uh we never really it was to that point
to where we we had mind control where he
had mind control over us we never had
that so um my time playing against him
it was really it was really all about
phillip rivers
what's the craziest thing you ever heard
phillip rivers say to you on a football
field
oh man a lot man i'm talking about i
can't even count how many games we
played against each other so i made
i remember one game i got a flag and he
was like ref say his full name
i was like
man and i ended up getting them later on
in that game but uh he's he's we've had
great battles for sure
yeah i mean he loves the sport he
reminds me of drew locke although locke
has a different approach but you sense
that passion and that enjoyment and that
that that just love for the game and the
love for competition and it and it makes
everyone's uh
intensity and level increase
yeah i mean you got to have that and um
especially from the quarterback a high
spirited quarterback i think is uh
that's why pat mc holmes is so great he
plays with a high level spirit tom brady
those guys been doing it for so long
because because of that and uh that's
what makes them great so how comfortable
are you with the guys that you have
going into camp tyrod taylor looks like
he'll be number one backed up by justin
herbert the sixth pick in the draft
i feel comfortable with those guys i
know tyrod um he's never got the the
real chance and real talent that he's
had um with the chargers now that since
his career i know in buffalo i mean i
think we played him but i can't really
name receivers that he was that he had i
can't uh i can't remember and uh
uh really i think his best weapon was
mccoy shady mccoy so uh he hasn't had
the weapons i think that he has now with
the chargers so i'm excited to see what
he can do with him yeah i think he's 26
and 23 as a starter took the bills to
the playoffs the year they lost the
jaguars in a close game the year the
jaguars almost beat the patriots for a
berth in the super bowl so there's
something there with tyrod and you guys
got some weapons on offense and you know
those guys well too keenan allen and
mike williams it's not and hunter henry
it's not going to be easy uh for
defenses to slow those guys down and
tyrod's good enough that he can get him
the football
yes he is and um i mean
like like you said man just be able to
orchestrate the football let those guys
do what they do
let echoler do what he do keenan he's
going to get open he's one of the best
route runners in the nfl so i just know
just competing versus those guys they
they they have it um to be able to to
make those plays man it's just getting
over that huh well chris we hope we get
to see it i said over the weekend i was
told the nfl is very optimistic the
season will be played there may not be
fans but we'll be watching and we wish
you all the best as you start your first
season with the la charges
congratulations on our success all the
best your family happy father's day a
day late and we look forward to talking
to you again down the road
oh yeah no problem man thanks for having
me
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports